جون كينغ ، دعونا نلقي نظرة الآن على
الطريق المؤدي إلى
أصوات الهيئة الانتخابية البالغة 270 صوتًا التي تحتاجها ليتم
انتخابك
رئيسًا ولهذا السبب فإن المحادثة التي
نتابعها مهمة جدًا ما هو
جمهور الناخبين وما هو
تكوين الناخبين الذي فيه  ينص على أن هذا
سيأخذنا شوطًا طويلاً إلى هناك ،
لكن جو بايدن يحاول القيام بأمرين
الليلة أنه يحاول استعادة
ما أخذ الرئيس
ترامب بنسلفانيا ميشيغان ويسكونسن من
الديمقراطيين الذين لم يتحولوا إلى اللون الأحمر منذ
عام 1992 كانوا في أيدي ديمقراطية
منذ عام 1992  لذا يحاول جو بايدن
استعادة الجدار الأزرق ،
حسنًا ، إنه يحاول الاحتفاظ بجميع
ولايات كلينتون التي ستكون كولورادو
التي
ستأتي عليك أن تغيرها بالنسبة لي هناك
تذهب إلى نيفادا
التي ستكون مينيسوتا
هامبشاير الجديد حسنًا ، لذا ها أنت ذاهب
لاستعادة ولايات كلينتون ،
سيوصلك إلى 278 هناك إذا كان بإمكانك
الحصول على بنسلفانيا ،
أقول فقط احصل على هذا ليس بالأمر السهل في
بنسلفانيا ميشيغا  في ولاية ويسكونسن ، يمكنك
استعادة هؤلاء ،
فأنت الرئيس القادم للولايات المتحدة ،
وهذا هو أول شيء يحاول فعله
لإعادة ولايات كلينتون إلى الوراء ولا تفقد
أيًا منها
، ثم استعادة هؤلاء الثلاثة الذين
كان هدف جو بايدن ، ثم يحاول فعل ما
كان آبي ودان وجيك يتحدثان
عما إذا كان لديك تنوع في
الناخبين الديمقراطيين الذين قالوا لبعض
الوقت أن
جورجيا ستكون في نهاية المطاف دولتنا
التي ننموها في ضواحي
الأمريكيين الأفارقة اللاتينيين أريزونا سيكون في
نهاية المطاف دولتنا.
في العقد الماضي ،
ستكون تكساس في نهاية المطاف قد
وضع ترامب هذا التطور على المنشطات
إذا نظرت إلى التركيبة السكانية
ستقول بعد عامين من الآن بعد أربع سنوات
من الآن ، ربما ست سنوات من الآن بعض تلك الدول ربما بعد ست
سنوات من الآن ولكن
وضع الناخبين ذلك  التحول
خاصة بسبب الضواحي
وإذا حصلت على زيادة
الإقبال على المشاركة من قبل الأمريكيين الأفارقة واللاتينيين ، فيمكن أن يقوم بايدن
بأشياء من هذا القبيل
في ضواحي شمال كارولينا بأمريكا الأفريقية
NS بالإضافة إلى الضواحي بالإضافة إلى الشباب
في فلوريدا ، والأمريكيين الأفارقة ، واللاتينوس ،
والضواحي وممر i-4 ، هل يمكنه فعل
شيء مثل أنه في متناول اليد ، هل
يمكنه فعل شيء
كهذا في متناول اليد ، وهذا ما
يحلم به الديمقراطيون الليلة لديهم
فرصة
الفرصة هي شيء واحد التنفيذ
والتشطيب هو شيء آخر ولكن هذا هو
مسار جو بايدن وحتى ذلك الحين ،
لذا فأنت تركت
جورجيا على الطاولة هناك ، لذا دعنا
نعود إلى خريطة الرئيس
لترامب ، ستعود إذا كنت
إذا كنت
شاغلًا للمنصب ،
ابدأ بهذا ونعلم أن
الرئيس ترامب مهووس بهذا الأمر حتى
يومنا هذا ، ويعطي نسخًا من هذه الخريطة ، هل
سيزوره الناس عندما يتحدث عن
الحملة
عندما يسافر هذا ما كان عليه
يتحدث عما إذا كنت ترامب
قد رأيته في الأيام القليلة الماضية
يقضي الكثير من الوقت
هنا وهنا يحب هذه الخريطة
لأنها جعلت منه رئيسًا ،
وهذا ليس انتقادًا بل هو
التزام  منة هذه هي الطريقة التي فاز بها بالرئاسة قبل أربع سنوات ، نعم ، وبالتالي فإن وجهة نظره هي الدفاع عنها ، إليك السؤال الذي نعلم أن معدل موافقته عليه في منتصف الأربعينيات من القرن الماضي ، نعلم أن جائحة الفيروس التاجي منتشر في جميع أنحاء البلاد ومن المحتمل أن يفقد شيئًا ما ، والسؤال هو إلى أي مدى يمكنه تحمل خسارته إذا فكرت في الأمر في وقت متأخر من الحملة ، كان تقدم بايدن في ميشيغان ثابتًا ومتسقًا إلى حد كبير لا يعني أن هذه هي الطريقة التي ستذهب بها هيلاري في نهاية المطاف. كانت الحملة الأخيرة لجو بايدن حوالي ضعف ذلك ، ولكن على دونالد ترامب الاستعداد لخسارة ميشيغان ، يجب أن يكون مستعدًا لأنه ربما يخسر ويسكونسن مرة أخرى ، حيث يحاولون زيادة عدد الناخبين اليوم ، فهذا ليس خارج نطاق الاحتمالات ولكن إذا كنت '' في الحملة الرابحة في الأيام الأخيرة ، يجب أن تكون مستعدًا لفرار هذين الشخصين ، كما يجب أن تكون مستعدًا لأنك ربما ستخسر ، يُفضل جو بايدن للفوز في مين بسهولة تامة
تخصص maine أصوات الكلية الانتخابية الخاصة بها حسب
منطقة الكونغرس.
يجب أن يكون الرئيس مستعدًا
لخسارة تلك الدائرة التي يجب أن يكون أيضًا على
استعداد لخسارة هذا التصويت لا يعني أنه سيفعل
ذلك ، لكن هذا هو التوقع داخل
الحملة الرابحة بناءً على كل
ما لديهم  نظرنا إليه في الأسبوع الأخير ، لذا فإن
هذا هو ما حدث هنا
، وبالتالي فإن ما سيحدث دونالد ترامب
سيظل عند 278
إذا كان بإمكانه الاحتفاظ بهذا إذا كان بإمكانه الاحتفاظ
ببنسلفانيا الآن
278 إذا كان بإمكانه الاحتفاظ بنسلفانيا ، فلا يزال
يتعين عليه التمسك شمالًا  كارولينا
عليه أن يحمل فلوريدا. عليه أن يحمل
جورجيا وعليه أن
يحمل أريزونا